so Michael Jordan is a billionaire most  people don't know that you think of him  as the greatest basketball player of all  time but he's actually a billionaire now  he only made only 90 million dollars  over his playing career so how is he  worth 1.6 billion dollars now well  because he owns part of the Charlotte  Hornets and Nike still to this days  paying him a hundred million dollars per  year in royalties the man-made 90  million over his entire playing career  and now he's making 100 million every  year from his Nike royalties it's a  reminder to step up and play a bigger  game are you thinking about the bigger  game are you just a talent for hire  trading your time for money or are you  trying to build an Empire like Michael  Jordan fun fact too Jordan didn't want  to sign with Nike originally he wanted  to sign with Adidas but at the time they  only wanted seven Footers interesting  turn of History